[Musique]
eh bien
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette
révolution technologique qu'on appelle à
la révolution des objets connectés
le moteur de cette révolution et
internet
c'est quand même fascinant à l'espace
d'une centaine d'années on a vu trois
révolutions et la dernière plus celle ci
où on est au coeur de cette révolution
là c'est quand même excitant c'est une
révolution qui s'annonce plein de
promesses mais aussi des risques
qu'est ce que c'est que les objets
connectés et bien l'autre jour mon
conjoint me rappelle une discussion
qu'il a eue avec son collègue qui lui
dit c'est fantastique je viens de
recevoir un courriel du dans un moteur
de recherche qui lui ai dit voilà le
bilan de votre année vous avez visité
temps pays
vous avez parcouru autant de kilomètres
votre rythme cardiaque est le suivant et
ça continue ainsi le collègue était tout
excité d'avoir ce bilan la très très
fier mais attention ce n'est pas aussi
simple que ça je vais vous en parler un
peu plus loin
imaginons dans un instant que les robots
sont devenus les nouveaux employés de
demain on assiste à une nouvelle
catégorie d'employés que je vais appeler
l'école gris ccal gris c'est fabuleux
prennent jamais de pause n'ont jamais de
vacances ne demande jamais de congés ne
se plaignent jamais de plus ces nouveaux
employés accomplissent des tâches
phénoménal ils peuvent soulever des
objets très lourds peuvent s'acquitter
de tâches routinières et de plus peuvent
occuper des postes de catégorie
professionnelle et oui grâce à leur
puissance de calcul
ils sont capables d'élaborer des
stratégies proposer des alternatives
faire des diagnostics à partir d'une
base de données performante
et identifier tout de suite le problème
par exemple une tumeur cancéreuse et ça
avec un taux d'1 faillibilité presque
vous trouvez que j'exagère eh bien non
cette réalité là elle peut être en place
du moins elle est en place dans certains
pays on de ces enjeux aussi c'est la
reconnaissance faciale
ces systèmes ultra performant imaginons
encore une fois que les systèmes de
reconnaissance faciale sont instaurés un
peu partout j'entre dans un
établissement scolaire on m'identifie on
connaît mon petit gris j'ai
l'autorisation ou pas de passer même
chose avec les systèmes de surveillance
tous ces systèmes lors favorisent ou
port la libre circulation on n'a plus
besoin de passeport
la vie serait devenu un peu plus facile
du moins pour certains
quels seraient les impacts sur la
société d'une telle société qui serait
en vigueur il ya plusieurs question
qu'on peut se poser quand on fait face
justement à ces données massives qu'on
utilise une de ces questions est la
suivante dans quelle société
voulons-nous vivre
quelle est la finalité du travail humain
serait encore utile à la société risk
temps de souffrir d'insignifiance ce
sont des questions qui m'apparaissent
majeur aujourd'hui dont il faut se poser
un matin en sortant de chez moi j'ai vu
un escargot puis je le regardais faire
sa trace et je me disais que aujourd'hui
c'est ça on laisse des traces numériques
et notre patrimoine de données et de
plus en plus transparent cette coque et
que l'on transporte sur soi à nos
informations personnelles et bien
maintenant sont accessibles sont
accessibles et elle représente
quand une valeur marchande énorme
on dit souvent que les données sont les
nourrissons sont le nouveau pétrole
d'aujourd'hui et ça représente de l'or
ce qui est paradoxal aujourd'hui dans
cette révolution technologique
c'est que les données appartiennent en
grande partie à des grands groupes
privés et non à des gouvernements que
font les entreprises privées avec nos
données
eh bien ils tentent de segmenter les
gens ils tentent de capter vos désirs
vos volontés tentent de coloniser vos
identités justement pour vous influencer
on le vus dans différents scandales qui
commencent à sortir présentement on peut
influencer les gens au plan politique on
peut influencer en diffusant des fausses
informations et ces fausses informations
sont possibles justement parce qu'on a
segmenté et on vous a catégorisé on vous
identifier êtes vous une personne
vulnérable
êtes vous une personne à risque toutes
les traces que vous laissez c'est facile
de les utiliser ces bases de données
servent à construire des algorithmes ans
les algorithmes c'est comme une recette
et peuvent être dans les mains de
n'importe qui imaginez encore une fois
une personne que beaucoup de bien et
qu'il déteste une catégorie de personnes
dans la population
elle peut très bien construire des
algorithmes et favoriser un groupe
d'individus au détriment des autres par
exemple ça peut être les hommes les
femmes les noirs les blancs les joncs
les rouges peu importe sans contrôle
extérieur
les algorithmes peuvent représenter un
risque les bases de données le fait
qu'elle soit un peu plus opaque de plus
en plus peuvent représenter aussi un
risque si on ne peut pas les expliquer
j'y vois trois dangers actuellement le
premier danger c'est l'ignorance
on en sait très peu sur ce qui se passe
présentement au niveau de nos traces
numériques de nos personnalités digital
qu on est en train de construire
présentement on est dans la facilité
donc on est somnambule
on suit le mouvement c'est facile tout
le monde le fait je choisis des fils
toujours les mêmes films je reste
toujours dans le même champ de fleurs
je ne vais jamais voir ailleurs parce
qu'on m'offre toujours la même chose
pour répondre à mes besoins
notre libre arbitre et très peu exercé
dans cette révolution là et nous devons
l'activer parce que nous devons poser
des questions sur l'utilisation de ces
données
un autre danger c'est l'absence de débat
public
on en discute pas et c'est c'était
question de démocratie
le fait que ya peu d'outils qui viennent
encadrer la les traces numériques les
lois n'arrive pas à suivre
on a besoin de prise pour comprendre le
réel est une de ces prises c'est
l'éthique
qu'est ce que l'éthique l'éthique c'est
une réflexion sur les valeurs que l'on
juge prioritaire dans le but de prendre
une décision juste
l'éthique ça demande une discipline
interne c'est pas facile ça demande de
la cohérence dans le bus comme finalité
ayant comme finalité le meilleur vivre
ensemble
l'éthique s'incarne dans l'acceptabilité
sociale et pour que ça dépasse les
intentions louables l'éthique s'incarne
dans la délibération
une délibération était qui permet de
débattre sur le quelles sont les valeurs
que l'on juge prioritaire aujourd'hui
quelles sont les valeurs que l'on veut
protéger
c'est un pouvoir avec les autres
le groupe dans lequel on participe c'est
à dire plus de 180 chercheurs au québec
on débat des questions pour mieux
anticiper les risques diminuer les
impacts négatifs de la neige
artificielle et du numérique afin de
conscientiser la société on s'inscrit
dans une innovation responsable
une entreprise qui voudraient justement
s'inscrire dans ce courant de
délibération éthique et d'innovation
responsables pourraient utiliser les
données des citoyens dire comment elles
utilisent les données
qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait est ce que
c'est pour l'avancement de la science
est ce qu'elle vend vos données à des
tiers elle explique comment elle va
utiliser le tout de façon transparente
de façon compréhensible de façon
explicable ça c'est une organisation qui
s'inscrit dans une innovation
responsable qui a à coeur le bénéfice de
la société
on est tous dit on est au tout début de
ces transformations là alors on est en
droit de demander des comptes on est en
droit d'exiger comment ces données leur
seront utilisés en terminant je voudrais
revenir avec le petit escargot parce que
j'aimerais ça que ça vous reste parce
que l'escargot c'est ça c'est ça traîne
votre patrimoine ce que vous avez de
plus précieux et vous le ferez
actuellement gratuitement et vous
poursuivez l'enrichissement des grandes
compagnies qui sont dans ce domaine là
et qu'elle ça aide à construire des
algorithmes très performante
alors la question que vous devriez vous
poser c'est est-ce que vous continuez à
être somnambule où vous voulez poser des
questions vous voulez exercer votre
libre arbitre pour justement pavé la
voie à une innovation responsable dans
cette transformation ruminer numérique
la passivité est un ges et ne pas agir a
des conséquences
alors vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous
ne serez pas prévenu si vous ne
participez pas à un débat de société
lorsque vous voyez des systèmes qui
s'installe sans poser de questions merci
de votre attention
[Applaudissements]